found footage horror got a fresh face
with this 2007 movie which proved that
you don't need a Gothic mansion or
dilapidated Cabin in the Woods to make a
highly effect of Haunting flick all the
action of Paranormal Activity takes
place in the comfy carpeted setting of a
Suburban town home as a pair of
newlyweds learned they're not entirely
alone in their house like its genre
predecessor The Blair Witch Project
Paranormal Activity is all about the
Slow Burn even the most ordinary
occurrences like a door swinging shut or
a hall light Illuminating offscreen are
imbued with for boing and the teeny tiny
Cass does a convincing job of making the
found footage premise feel real